(audience cheering)
- Alright y'all,
sometimes it feels like
there's nothing positive
on social media, but that is not true.
There's a lot of beauty in the world,
y'all just have to look for it.
This is "#What I'm Liking".
(energetic piano music)
(audience clapping)
Alright, it's no secret
kids love superheroes,
especially in my house, adults as well.
I want you to check
out these photos though
of a three-year-old girl
in a Spider-Man costume.
(giggles) She's so cute, so adorable,
and her mother cut two
holes on the costume
so her natural hair would come out.
Those pictures have been
shared nearly 80,000 times
from everyone from Kerry
Washington to Viola Davis
to Michael B. Jordan,
they've all commented.
Let's get this mini superhero in here.
Say "Hi" to Rose and her momma Diamond,
(audience cheering)
I mean Spider-Girl
and her momma Diamond.
Alright, gosh,
you are so cute!
So, Diamond, I get the impression
that Rose does not take
this costume off much.
- Correct, at this moment,
it's only to take a bath.
We saw the Spider-Man
costume one day in Party City
for Halloween.
So for her birthday I decided to upgrade
and cut the holes in
it and take the picture
so she will remember her third birthday,
how obsessed she was with Spider-Man.
- Oh my god, I mean it's so funny,
literally this looks like my house,
like my son would be in Spider-Man,
and my girl would be Gwen
in the Spider-Verse one.
So they're literally going
around just "poof-poof"
my house like all night long.
So why do you think
people responded, though,
the way they have to the photo?
- The Afro posts were a big hit.
I really think it shows
that you can actually
be whatever you want to be,
and that Black girls can be
whatever they want to be.
- [Kelly] Absolutely! Oh my
gosh, you little model baby!
She is so, you are so
cute behind that mask
is what I'm sayin'!
(audience cheering)
So I feel like, Spider-Girl,
your favorite moves seems
to be like kinda like
the flock of flyin'...
What's your favorite superhero move?
Is it this one?
- [Diamond] Are you showing it?
- [Kelly] Is that your...
Yes!
(audience clapping)
Alright!
(Kelly giggles and claps)
Well, thank you so much Diamond
and thank you Spider-Girl Rose!
I'm likin' y'all's post right now.
- [Diamond] Thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Alright, that's not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot pen makers of FriXion,
the Go-To Erasable Pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly.
Angel's looking awesome, she can go,
you're gonna want this part anyway.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars,
how's that sound, Diamond?
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much!
(Kelly giggles and claps)
- [Kelly] You can buy so many
Spider-Man memorabilia stuff with that.
Thank y'all so much!
Have a blessed day!
(audience cheering)